hi there everybody I'm here with cast
members from the biggest movie in the
universe Marvel's Avengers infinity war
Chris Hemsworth Anthony Mackie Chris
Pratt or Scarlett Johansson and thank
you all for joining me we moved our show
into a storage room of a Holiday Inn
Express near the on-ramp to the 405
freeway why not we come to you okay
normally the shows in Burbank all right
they said they don't want to come to
Burbank I said screw them I paid over 65
dollars by cardboard foam core Andy said
he'd bring in his van they recreated the
set this is all for you so the pressures
on Wow Thank you very
what's that Anthony I didn't hear you
didn't say anything I thought you said I
was a good man nope Sly's he said I was
a good man you're a good man it doesn't
get sweeter than this right now the
energy in this room is something we can
feed on that's it
for the next 15 minutes until there's a
bar mitzvah here and we have to get out
let's start because there isn't a lot of
time that water's not cheap take it easy
all right
yes go easy on it okay one sip for
segment
you